hey guys have you ever wondered why most
celebrities and models out there it just
always looks like they have clear skin
they never have pimples and well it just
looks really good now a lot of people
say well it's just because they're
models or they're celebrities no
it's not because they are better than
you for some reason
it's just because they put in the effort
and they know how to take good care of
their skin
now I've been a model for a long time
and I've always taken good care of my
skin so let me tell you how I always
take care of my skin to have clear skin
good looking skin at all times I'm going
to tell you a few things that I've never
shared on this channel before
let's get to it
[Music]
just very quick if it's the first time
that you're here and if you want content
for men everything that's important
everything has got to do with men that's
honest that's accurate and that's not
going to waste your time that's going to
bring value to your life then subscribe
and you won't regret it now I'm gonna
give you three important tips
Advanced Skin Care tips that will help
you to have clear skin let's start with
number one
you need a good basic skincare routine
this is just basic when it comes to skin
care because your skin is not going to
look that great without a basic good
skin care routine
why because over time you will get sun
damage you'll get dirt in your pores
you'll get sebum causing pimples and
blackheads and well you will just get
old so your skin will get worse as time
moves on
so a basic skincare routine works like
this first you need to wash your face at
least two times a day when you wake up
in the morning
[Music]
and before you sleep at night
a third time as well if you work out if
you work out every day after your
workout you need to wash your face as
well you need to use a good cleanser
that penetrates deep enough into your
skin to prevent those pimples and
blackheads
and then you need to put on the right
ingredients with a cream afterwards so
that it will give your skin what it
needs to look good
[Music]
thank you
now I have just shown you my own
personal skincare routine and the brand
that I've been using for a long time is
called geology it's amazing brand it
works it's personalized skin care that
means it's personalized it's customized
made specifically for you for your
specific skin I reached out to them and
said hey guys I'm going to make this
video really sponsor it and also give my
viewers a big discount and I said yes so
if you want to check them out I've added
all the details in the video description
down below with the big discount code as
well all you need to do is to go on
their website and answer a few questions
about your skin type and their
dermatologist will create a skincare
routine specifically for you and they'll
send it right to your house
it's as easy as that let's move on to
number two
the second tip is vitamin C
why
well
let me explain it to you this way when
we are babies and even young kids why do
we always have good looking skin and
then when we grow up it just looks well
not so clear anymore it's because of
vitamin C it's actually part of our skin
you know in the top layers but as we
grow older the vitamin C gets less and
less and our bodies cannot effectively
store the vitamin C we get from food
back into our skin and then sun damage
and pollution makes it even worse and
over time your skin starts to look
duller and kind of uneven
yeah this is why so many people out
there have uneven skin and they don't
know why it's because of the vitamin C
so how do you get that vitamin C back
into your skin if you can't get it from
food you get it from trusted products
you can also get it directly from
geology but geology is Vitamin C also
comes with vitamin E ferulic acid and
hyaluronic acid which all add to
improving your skin tone this is the
perfect formula that brightens skin tone
and Fades away dark spots
and then of course if you are like me
who's slowly getting older I mean I'm 36
right now so I know you know as I age
I'm gonna get more and more wrinkles
and so this product also helps for
wrinkles
now the last thing that I want to talk
about and yes this is the last thing we
don't need to talk about millions of
products like a lot of channels do we
are men less is more and we only need to
focus on the products that actually work
and so what I want to talk about
is a clay mask but not just any clay
mask I mean there are thousands out
there and most of them you don't need
and they don't actually work that great
there's one just one that I want to
suggest this three minute volcanic sand
exfoliator and Eucalyptus clay mask it
has lactic glycolic and salicylic acid
with tea tree oil powdered volcanic sand
Kalin and bentonite clay so this is
basically an exfoliator and a mask in
one it's great for your skin and you
don't need to use this every day you
just need to use it once a week so it
saves you time and money now if you use
all of these tips it will definitely
help you to have better looking clear
skin if you want more tips check out
these videos here and I'll see you there
and always remember life is short so
don't waste yours cheers guys